hey what's up everyone i'm bravo and
i've stuck my way back inside the 343
industry studio to check out a world
premiere of ranked and competitive
gameplay and i have the two best
gentlemen to do it with me here it's l
town sao of course of the competitive
insights team long time pro player great
to be with you again man and also andrew
witts lead designer on halo infinite
guys it's uh great to be with you today
i want to jump right in because like we
said the world premiere here of
competitive and ranked settings and
we're going to have game plan just a
moment but before we get into that
gameplay android i'd love to talk a
little bit about the philosophy of of
ranked and competitive gameplay for halo
infinite we looked at competitive
settings the same way that we looked at
the rest of the game like we haven't
talked about it we wanted to be very
very halo to its core right and like
uphold the pillars of halo we really
wanted to make sure that this uh the
competitive settings felt like
competitive hill like home battle rifle
starts only no secondary weapon
no motion tracker uh and no grenade hit
ticks so it's the baseline settings
across the game
for maps we have a static curated spawns
we work with the competitive insights
team to make sure that the scavenging
story on maps is really strong and
facilitates match control we want to
make sure the the team that wins is the
team that should win sure uh you'll have
to excuse me because i'm containing my
excitement here and i know a lot of a
lot of
fans of competitive halo over the years
will be really excited to hear about
these settings too uh and and also to
see them in action so i think let's go
ahead and jump right into the game play
uh right now of course i'll time this is
gonna be your game play that you've been
so kind to share with us this is going
to be a full pro team competitive
insights gameplay which is pretty cool
to see kind of all of you guys who have
been going at each other over the years
playing a game now here of strongholds
on recharge
those of you who've been playing in the
halo infinite flight weekends will of
course have been able to get your hands
on this exact game type but we're going
to now see it for the first time from a
competitive pov with competitive
settings of course also with some pro
player point of view so sal walk us
through the opening here strongholds on
recharge so this is strongholds
obviously you have to go for all the
strongholds but we're going for mid
control here and camo and my teammates
are mid-map kind of forcing those two
players into me i get the easy double i
get the triple as well where is it
and apparently i get the overkill too
yes i do so not a bad start complete
control and now i'm capping c not bad at
all not bad at all
i'm wondering i mean you know these guys
pretty well i don't know if any like
cash was exchanged to allow you to open
up with an overkill here on this world
premiere of competitive gameplay but
excited to to be able to look at this
gameplay here i think one of the first
things that we of course want to talk
about is that stronghold has a game type
you're just talking about game modes
andrew and the fact that we have a
little bit of different scoring
mechanics here which make a big
difference in terms of the end game
stronghold is returning from halo 5
really thought that it did very well in
halo 5 and it was well regarded by the
competitive community so we want to
iterate on it in meaningful ways and one
of those meaning wonderful ways is uh
how to contest and how scoring works in
strongholds when you own two zones you
begin scoring and now if the enemy enemy
team captures any progress towards one
of your zones it stops your scoring run
so that way you need to maintain
absolute control over all of your all of
your captured zones to continue scoring
yeah absolutely i think it's a great
change anyone who played a lot of halo 5
or watched a lot of halo 5 strongholds
will remember scenarios where they had
all the pieces in place to maybe get a
perfect comeback and even though they
were halfway through the cap on that
stronghold they needed uh as you call it
like the drip time allowed the other
team to win it felt a little bit
anticlimactic so i think a lot of people
have already seen in the halo infinite
flights the ability to stop everything
on the dime and come back is is pretty
fantastic to see
another thing we'll talk about here of
course is equipment style we're already
seeing you kind of use that equipment
and make sure that you're using grapple
to be everywhere you need to be on the
map right now yep just making sure i'm
getting resets and strongholds and
helping my team by getting those quick
flanks and quick routes
another thing we should talk about
of course is such a big piece of this
that we're going to see is just the fact
that we have motion tracker disabled and
how that impacts
moment-to-moment gameplay throughout the
entirety of competitive play you're
gonna see a lot of examples of that of
course in this game but we should talk
guys andrew i'll start with you just
about the decision there and just how
much that impacts the gameplay
yeah we really wanted um the game to be
as competitive as possible working with
but have insights team to to kind of
make sure we measure up in that regard
and and part of the things one of the
things we wanted to kind of focus on was
awareness right awareness and
communication being really pivotal to uh
which is the better team that wins so
that's why we pursued that direction and
you'll see a lot of the of the outcomes
here in terms of how that rolls
yeah absolutely you put it best when we
were talking earlier just before we
started recording just you know talking
about information
earned and the fact that versus
absolutely um just how important that is
yeah so we wanted players to actually
have to go out their way and get info
themselves versus like an indicator or
ui telling you where players are and how
weak they are so it's just more more
awareness and more skills and more
thought process on this yeah absolutely
uh as we take a look here uh about 70 to
56 still a pretty close game here uh as
you're going to get oh and get another
reset here but you guys are doing pretty
well in terms of just ability to
continually rotate and collapse on the
opponent as well
yep just using some good comms here
collapsing on stronghold together
and nice pain switching going on right
here yeah absolutely
i think another thing we should talk
about too as you're going to go ahead
and get this kill back hydro you're
gonna be able to pick up we're gonna see
some sort and some equipment place it's
probably a good opportunity to talk
about some of the equipment balance in
the game so right here i pair for pulsar
and sword
to use to get some creative shortcuts
here right that guy had no idea so that
movement that shortcut mixed in with no
uh motion tracker
this allows you to make crazy plays like
that honestly yeah absolutely there's so
many pieces to talk about there just the
fact that you can creatively go from
bottom middle all the way up to top a
like that with the sword like you said
if someone is watching motion tracker in
a competitive setting they're going to
be watching that doorway that play
doesn't really happen in those settings
so it's pretty fantastic to see and by
the way everyone's just running away
from you with their heads down at this
point in the game as you're racking up
even more kills but that brings us
perfectly actually to a camo pickup and
the first thing we'll talk about here is
just the new mechanic andrew of course
people have seen it but it's worth
talking to to to you as the designer on
the decision there of course uh in
conjunction with the sandbox team to to
make sure that the camo is actually
pocketable and you can determine when
you want to activate it
yeah the the sandbox team did an awesome
job working on the the power equipment
in this game and so being able to pocket
uh power equipment and it taking the
spot of other equipment really brings
more agency in terms of how you want to
use the these items to your advantage
right and also hard decision making halo
is always about making a million
decisions like having a million
decisions to to do in a given second
right and what's the best one
and this kind of adds to that right is
do i swap grapple shot for overshield
and do i use it now and then pick uh the
grapple shot back up what do i do what
is my combinatory effects with based on
what my current inventory is do i market
for the other teammates to kind of come
and pick up and contest with me
these are all the kind of questions we
asked of ourselves and and ultimately
you see here today is the fruit of those
labors right and make sure that we test
the hypothesis and it worked
yeah it's pretty incredible to see just
you know the term equipment on its own
and the history of competitive halo has
been
kind of a you know a a term that has uh
had an ebb and flow over the years of
how does equipment fit or not fit into
competitive halo so to see how much it's
not only being accepted but i would even
say embraced with things like clips on
twitter twitch etc has been pretty
amazing i'd love to talk about that
quickly just kind of the all-up
philosophy of
how you found this sweet spot balance
with the equipment that's in the game
that gives players some creativity
we wanted to make sure that the
equipment added to the skill of the game
right with us the skill gap and then the
skill ceiling so the combinatory effects
of like we saw before with sal with the
repulsor as well as the the energy sword
right like the ability to traverse the
map the way he did adds that skill uh
both for uh newcomer players and also
pro players like themselves like the
experimentation the expression
was really important for us in
development in terms of adding these
things in
and then
fitting in with everything else in the
sandbox
sure here's another camo pickup sally
you guys have really been on top of that
camo and activated immediately and
probably the most interesting thing to
talk about there
right is the lack of grenade hit markers
that that player would have had in that
situation yep exactly so that player
actually had no idea how much damage he
was actually doing or if he was even
hitting me yeah he had to go out of his
way to make sure that i was weak and get
the kill on me
my play right there was to make him
waste as much time as possible and to
put him in a spot where my teammates
could get the cleanup trade on him
absolutely and that's a situation that
plays out completely differently with
both motion tracker and grenade hit
markers on also forces that player to
even spend those grenades right so it
really changes the way that that plays
out it allows you to have so much more
power as a player there you're burning
camo you're spending that players
grenades and you're also taking that
player out of the situation there's
probably at least going to be a trade
there and it really changes the way that
all that plays out yup absolutely
another thing i'd love to talk about
here as we see more continuous control
from the salon team andrew is also just
a dynamic between of course we've got
the br utility weapon that so many
players will be excited to see but we're
also seeing sal use a lot of mangler
we're seeing some commando how you guys
really thought about the dynamic between
this utility weapon is really important
and it is such a core part of the
gameplay however the weapons on the
battlefield are also a big piece as well
yeah i think the sandbox team did a
really excellent job of making sure that
all the weapons have a specific role in
the game the battle rifle being the
utility weapon is really important to
being for players to being viable off of
spawn right they're having expression
off of spawn but we didn't want to have
have um
scavenging is so important to the game
right since we wanted to keep on having
them scavenge the battlefield how we did
that was we took away that secondary
weapon slot and have it be free so it's
only the battle rifle off of spawn and
so optimizers will want to fill their
inventory fill their pockets in order to
be able to be as effective as they
possibly can in a match so going with
that scavenging story of the map being
very curated with very specific items
and toys in the map and you know filling
up that their inventory is is super
important
absolutely we see another camo grab here
from sal as well
this time i live that's a nice job
they're gonna be able to uh
to get away and also uh you know of
course be able to go away now with a
grapple camo mangler which is a pretty
sweet setup as well pretty ideal
see what i do with it
let's go ahead and see it at this point
of course it's right now 216 to 137 or
one thing worth talking about with that
new score in mechanic salads one sec we
got a contested stronghold here let's
see how you play this one out okay well
done
uh takes down the first player i'm gonna
go ahead and finish that cap or almost
finish it but instead go ahead and up
nice grapple out but
yeah that's okay it's okay uh one thing
we should talk about though at this
point because even though there's quite
a gap right quite a delta between the
scores in the game you really can't take
your foot off the gas whereas in halo 5
you might be a little more comfortable
because you know you have as long as you
have control with x amount of time left
you're probably going to win the game
but with the ability to stop everything
like we said earlier immediately while
just stepping into a stronghold that
kind of changes the way that competitor
teams will play the late game
especially with the new rule set where
you could contest and stop the pausing
for a little bit like you can't let your
your foot off the gas you got to try to
close out the game here so just making
sure we keep up the comms and the
teamwork
just pushing strongholds together
yeah absolutely and you've done it so
well here as well take a look at this
play as well as you're going to go ahead
and grapple him
unlucky
i'm lucky indeed but it's just worth
noting the fact that you do have kind of
that creativity right i mean
never has there been in competitive halo
a
a moment like that where you could fly
out of a door and then fly into an
entryway like that and be able to just
set up a play like that so it's pretty
special to see and the fact that it is
balanced the way that it is right is i'm
sure was quite a challenge andrew uh for
for a long time i'm sure
yeah we uh we tested a lot of different
things a lot of different settings but
we want to make sure that the things
that the grapple and really all the
equipment had had that expression
element right the things that are
powering all those clips that you're
seeing on the internet we're seeing that
we're all gleefully seen on the internet
we want to make sure that uh it's
important for expression with equipment
i want to do this i want to do this and
this i want to repulse somebody and then
follow up with with that mangler melee
or things like i want to put somebody
into a wall and knock them off the map
uh expression is paramount for for some
of the designs we've done this game
certainly i've seen some expression in
the forms of being repulsored off the
back of silo there by the hammer many
many times in matchmaking i've also
been on the receiving end of uh
overshield grappling hammer players on
behemoth so i've definitely seen
different forms of that expression um
getting the better of me uh throughout
these weekends uh as we take a look at
these last few seconds here sal closing
it out i think we're gonna see
uh in just a moment you guys close this
out yes some celebratory needler shots
to end the game what better way to
finish a match as well 250 to 170 is our
final score there uh sal you guys ended
out on top a pretty strong performance
i'm not gonna lie appreciate it
we'll go ahead and take a look at the
post game cards report too because
there's some sweet pgcr stats and some
people will have seen a little bit of
this in the post game carnage reports in
the flighting but a few things that are
worth highlighting here of course you're
overkill but on top of that you've got
some cool things here in terms of
defensive kills offensive kills also
things like the max spree which people
will be familiar with but there's some
newcomers as well returning stats like
shots hit uh you know versus shots fired
but also one that you and i were talking
about is also damage taken which is a
cool stat down that's personally my
favorite because that is like the unsung
hero it tells a real story because some
players might have the most kills but
they're actually not having the most
influence on a map so damage taken is
part of that story where a person could
be causing chaos and getting shot out
from everyone on the opposing team like
a distraction like for example like
austin might have more kills but i could
be taking more damage because i'm making
it easier for him you know yeah
absolutely and as and as a commentator
as an analyst the fact that we now have
a piece of that story if you think of
the
uh hundreds of thousands of hours of
competitive halo gameplay that have
taken place uh just the fact that we've
never really had the story andrew of
damage taken and and what that was for
each match so the fact that looking at
halo infinite tournaments we're going to
have have stats like that is pretty cool
to be able to see a piece of a halo
match uh that we've never really had the
story of before yeah it's just all this
con this conversation around stats and
pgcr just kind of makes me really happy
because um ultimately that's what this
is this this whole feature is for right
is to tell the story of the match of
knowing how did you how did you do how
did your team do how did the enemy team
do right where do you need to uh improve
right or how could you've done things
better uh really that whole story is why
features like this exist and so that
we're sitting here talking about like
nuanced stats and things like that it's
like it's really good just like being in
this moment how close we are to to
launch totally yeah i think it gets us
excited i'm sure so many viewers as well
of this video getting kind of excited
about the those nuanced little details
just like you say uh l town i'll start
with you uh any any closing words uh as
we take a look at uh your game play here
and show off competitive and ranked
gameplay to the world honestly i'm just
excited for everyone to get their hands
on this we worked hard and i hope
everyone's happy with the settings we
landed on yeah absolutely
yeah likewise uh
myself and the rest of the team we work
on this for for a while really excited
to see uh uh folks you know uh get their
hands on it right the flights have been
really exciting for us are really
invigorating for us to see the response
and all the feedback right uh it's the
same thing here we're really excited to
see uh what the competitive community uh
does with this game with these settings
uh see what they're able to accomplish
in matches right see what ranked is like
see what hcs is like all this is just
super super great right now it's a good
it's a good time to be a halo fan yeah
it is as a halo fan and on behalf of the
whole community i just want to thank you
both for the amount of time love effort
you've put into this game because it is
already showing um in in you know in the
flighting in the excitement for the game
um and it was so special for me to play
such a small role in sitting with you
two with all the amount of work you've
put into this game to be part of this
competitive reveal is really special for
me so thank you both there's going to be
more information on haloway.com on
competitive settings and you can find a
blog on even more details there of
course stay tuned to halo on twitter as
well as halo waypoint for even more as
we get ready of course and also at hcs
as we get ready for the first halo
tournament shortly after launch as well
that's going to do it for us for now
from the 343 live stream studio it's
been a pleasure showing off competitive
gameplay and we'll see you on december
8th
[Music]
you